[Music]
last week the YouTube channel hit
100,000 subscribers so I wanted to send
a huge thank you out to everybody at the
end of the day this is just a big group
project between you the community and
myself with a goal of building something
that we can all benefit from and learn
from and I'm also super grateful for how
nice this community is as you probably
know a lot of YouTube comments can get
pretty ugly and even asking questions on
Stack Overflow can get pretty ugly if
you ask the wrong thing but I feel like
this has been one of the most helpful
and polite communities that I've ever
been a part of so I feel like I have to
be one of the luckiest youtubers out
there my original plan for reaching this
milestone was to give away a t-shirt or
maybe a Tesla but based on your feedback
it seems like a better option might be
to offer a full free course and that's
what I intend to do I already have plans
sketched out for a code this not that
full force that just covers the
fundamentals of JavaScript even though
most apps in the real world are going to
require a framework knowing how to do
things in vanilla JavaScript is very
liberating as developer that course will
be entirely free and you can look
forward to it shipping sometime in March
but there's a few other things on the
roadmap that'll come first I have a
straight payments course that is
underway right now and will be released
by the end of this month and also now
that ionic 4 is out I'm going to update
the ionic 4 master course and bring that
over to fire ship and also I have a
native app in development for fire ship
and that app will provide supplemental
content like quizzes for the actual
courses themselves and of course you can
expect a full flutter course shortly
after that app is released the last
thing I want to talk about is the
migration process for pro members of
angular firebase to fire ship I've built
an entirely new membership platform for
reasons that I explained in the previous
channel update and it's the pro
membership that really makes this
project sustainable so doing a migration
like this is very risky for me and very
annoying for you to make it as painless
as possible I'm just going to discount
the [ __ ] out of the new membership for
existing members if you're a lifetime
member you'll automatically get lifetime
access on fire ship if you're a monthly
or quarterly member you'll get a
discount code for 75% off of the
membership rate that means you'll be
able to walk in a rate of around $5 per
month that gives you access to all of
the premium courses and pro features
that I produce in the future it's
probably not a great business idea but
it's something I feel good about doing
just because that early pro membership
support is what really allowed this
channel to flourish so if you're an
existing angular firebase Pro member
you'll get that email most likely
sometime next week
I'll go ahead and wrap up the update
there if you have any questions reach
out on slack thanks for watching and I
will talk to you soon
[Music]